the daily routine in the prison was up  in the morning and then exercise  then everybody's uh [ __ ] out into the  yard  to begin with I was lucky for other  Englishmen  there wasn't anybody there  I was just a forum that surrounded by  other farmers  that didn't occur to me that they could  be my enemy one day night started  walking around the yard  suddenly from behind I was somebody  grabbed my elbow and then asked me deme  carefully - hombre amigo he wants me to  buy him a coffee I just had no  a produced up nine inch long shower  now it's life-saving time he lunges at  me my instincts took over  his friend went to pick up the shank I  mean a heightened state of adrenaline  they all looked at me they all knew the  lone Brits is a serious person because  I'm a martial artist that's how I  survived in prison